today
keeping our commitment to this house i'd
like to provide an update on our review
of preparedness for autumn and winter
the plan shows how we'll give this
nation the best possible chance of
living with covid without the need for
stringent social and economic
restrictions
there are five pillars to this plan mr
speaker
first
further strengthening our pharmaceutical
defenses like vaccines
the latest statistics from the ons show
that almost 99 of covered 19 deaths in
the first half of this year were people
who had not received both doses of a
covid19 vaccine
this shows the importance of our
vaccination program and by extending
this program further we can protect even
more people
almost 6 million people over the age of
16 remain unvaccinated in the uk
and the more people that are
unvaccinated the larger the holes in our
collective defenses
so we'll renew our efforts to maximize
uptake amongst those that are eligible
but have not yet for whatever reason
taken up the offer
next
we've been planning our booster doses
too
like with many other vaccines there's
evidence that the protection offered by
covert 19 vaccine reduces over time
particularly older people who are at
greater risk
and so booster doses are an important
way of keeping the virus under control
for the long term
this morning we published the jcvi's
advice on a booster program they
recommended that people who were
vaccinated in phase one that is priority
groups one to nine should be offered a
booster vaccine
that this vaccine should be offered no
earlier than six months after the
completion of the primary vaccine course
and that as far as possible the booster
program should be deployed in the same
order as phase one
i can confirm that i have accepted the
jcvi's advice and that the nhs is
preparing to offer booster doses from
next week
the nhs will contact people at the right
time and nobody needs to come forward at
this point
this this booster program it will
protect the most vulnerable through the
winter months and strengthen our wall of
defense even further
as well as this
we'll be extending the offer of a
covered 19 vaccine to even more people
as the minister for covert 19 vaccine
deployment announced yesterday in the
house and thank you mr speaker for
allowing him to make that statement
yesterday
all young people aged 16 to 17 in
england have already been offered a dose
of a covered 19 vaccine to give them the
protection as they return to school
and yesterday the uk's chief medical
officers unanimously recommended making
a universal offer of a first dose of a
vaccine to people aged between the ages
of 12 and 15.
the government has accepted this
recommendation too and will move with
urgency to put this into action
we're also seeing great advances in the
use of antivirals and therapeutics
several covert 19 treatments are already
available through the nhs and our
antivirals task force is leading the
search for breakthroughs in antivirals
which have so much more potential to
offer
second mr speaker
testing tracing and self-isolation have
been another vital defense
over the ultimate and winter pcr testing
for those with covert 19 symptoms and
contacts of confirmed cases will
continue to be available free of charge
regular asymptomatic testing
which identifies currently around a
quarter of all reported cases will also
continue in the coming months with a
focus on those who are not fully
vaccinated perhaps those in education or
in other higher risk settings
and contact tracing will continue
through the nhs test and trace system
we don't want people to face hardship
for as they carry out their duty to
self-isolate so for those that are still
required to self-isolate we'll keep
offering practical and financial support
to people who are eligible and need
assistance and will review these
regulations and this support by the end
of march 2022
our third pillar mr speaker is that
we're supporting the nhs and social care
last week i announced a 5.4 billion
pound injection for the nhs to support
the covert 19 response over the next six
months
including one billion pounds extra to
tackle the elective backlog caused by
covert 19.
we've also launched a consultation on
protecting vulnerable patients by making
covid19 and flu vaccinations a condition
of deployment for frontline healthcare
staff and wider so wider social care
workers in england
we're already making this a condition of
deployment for people in cqc registered
adult care homes
and although we are keeping an open mind
and we won't be making a final decision
until we fully consider the results of
the consultation i believe that it is
highly likely that frontline nhs staff
and those working in wider social care
settings will also have to be vaccinated
to protect those that are around them
and that this will be an important step
in protecting those at greatest risk
fourth mr speaker we'll be we'll keep
encouraging people to take steps to keep
seasonal illnesses at bay including flu
and cope 19.
the best step that we can all take is to
get vaccinations for covid19 and flu if
we're eligible
and so along with our covert 19
vaccination program the next few months
we'll see the largest ever flu
vaccination campaign this country has
ever seen
our plan also sets out a number of
changes we can all make to our daily
routines like meeting outdoors where
possible or if you need to be indoors
trying to let in fresh air wearing a
face mask in crowded and enclosed spaces
where you can come into contact with
people that you don't normally meet
and
and mr speaker
our fifth pillar
is how we'll look beyond our shores and
pursue an international approach last
week i attended the g20 health ministers
meeting and i met counterparts from
across the world and i talked about the
part that we'll be playing to lead the
global effort to accelerate access to
vaccines to therapeutics and to
diagnostics
and as we do this we'll maintain our
strong defenses at the border allowing
us to identify and to respond to
variants of concern
it's these defenses and the progress of
vaccination campaigns both here and
abroad that have allowed us to manage
the risks and to start carefully
reopening international travel once
again
we've already relaxed the rules for
fully vaccinated travelers and i asked
the cma to review the issue of
exploitative behavior in the private
testing market
this review reported last week and i'm
looking into what further action we can
take
and i can also update honourable members
that on top of these measures we'll be
publishing a new framework for
international travel i my right
honourable friend the transport
secretary will be announcing more
details ahead of the formal review point
on the first of october
thanks to the defensive we've built
we've been able to remove many of the
regulations that have governed our daily
lives rules that were unprecedented yet
necessary and our plan shows how we'll
be removing more of these powers while
maintaining those that are essential for
our response
this includes expiring more of the
powers in the coronavirus act
so for example those powers directing to
temporary closure of educational
institutions
the remaining provisions will be those
that are critical to the government's
response to the pandemic for example
making sure that the nhs is properly
resourced and supporting statutory sick
pay for those who are self-isolating
mr speaker the plan before the house
today is our plan a a comprehensive plan
to steer this country through the autumn
and winter
but we've seen how quickly this virus
can adapt and change
so we have prepared a plan b
of a contingency measures that we can
call upon only if they are needed and
supported by the data to prevent
unsustainable pressure on the nhs
these measures would be
communicating clearly and urgently to
the public the need for caution
legally mandating face coverings in
certain settings
and whilst we're not going ahead with
mandatory vaccine owning covert status
certification now we'll be holding that
power in reserve
as well as these three steps
we'd conti we would consider a further
measure of asking people to work from
home if they can for a limited time if
that is supported by the data
any responsible government must prepare
for all eventualities and although these
measures are not an outcome that anyone
wants it's one that we need to be ready
for just in case
mr speaker
ever since we published our roadmap to
recovery seven months ago we've been
carefully but cautiously getting this
nation closer to normal life
now we've come so far we've achieved so
much we must stay vigilant as we
approach this critical chapter
so that we can protect the progress that
we have all made together i commend this
statement to the house